claro el juez del distrito de Columbia
MS Sullivan había dictaminado ayer que
tenía que terminarse inmediatamente esta
medida el título 42 para adultos y para
familia recordemos que no se aplicaba
para menores de edad el juez había
calificado esta medida como arbitraria y
caprichosa Y entonces fue ahí
inmediatamente cuando el departamento de
Justicia le pide que por favor
postergara esta decisión de eliminar la
medida del título 42 para dentro de
cinco semanas para el 21 de diciembre y
esto pues diciendo nuevamente que la
medida era pues arbitraria y caprichosa
y pues afectaba a muchas personas que
trataban de pedir asilo en este país se
calcula que desde que entró en marcha
hace tres años la medida del título 42
se han expulsado de Estados Unidos
2,5 millones de inmigrantes de todos
crisis de Venezuela Nicaragua
Centroamérica Cuba y incluso ucranianos
que han tratado de entrar por la
frontera sur de Estados Unidos
hay mucha crítica bastante respuestas
frente a esta polémica de suspender la
medida del título 42 que recordemos fue
impuesta por Donald Trump porque esto
podría derivar en Pues en una ola
migratoria aún más grande que está
recibiendo Estados Unidos en este
momento hay cifras récords de emigrantes
que están tratando de cruzar la frontera
sur de Estados Unidos y al levantar esta
medida pues esto afectaría y aumentaría
posiblemente el número de migrantes que
traten de llegar a Estados Unidos Esa es
la crítica de los republicanos que
además fue una de las cartas de campaña
que se jugaron
agrandando esta crisis migratoria que ya
vivió Estados Unidos y diciendo que
precisamente al levantar esta medida
Pues podría aumentar el número de
migrantes que llegan a Estados Unidos
así que pues bastante rea sin embargo
Esto fue una promesa de campaña de Joe
biden Y pues con esta decisión pues se
cumple este esta Promesa de haber
levantado el título 42 y darle la
posibilidad a los inmigrantes de aplicar
asilo político en Estados Unidos